tu es la frontière biélorusse que cette
guerre a commencé puisque c'est de là
que s'étaient élancés les premiers
soldats le 24 février dernier pour aller
sur kiev mais l'offensive éclair s'est
très vite transformée en défaite bonjour
cyril payen vous êtes l'envoyé spécial
de france 24 avec mohamed farhat vous
étiez dans la région de tchernobyl
le site avait été occupée par les russes
aujourd'hui les envahisseurs sont loin
qu'avez vous constaté sur place
bae côté déjà que les infrastructures
sont extrêmement détruite par les armes
pour preuve qui nous avons très peu de
réseaux et de connexion
pour pouvoir déjà vous joindre par
téléphone ont cassé effectivement on est
déjà dans une forme d'après guerre ici
trois mois après l'entrée des premières
unités russes dans cette région ouest de
kiev nous étions avec mohammad farhad
beaulieu de boules vivier ce matin à
tchernobyl tchernobyl ces sept centrales
nucléaires qui avait explosé en
1986 et dont qui a de nouveau défrayé la
chronique il y a trois mois jour pour
jour puisque à 4 heures du matin bien la
frontière biélorusse à 2 à 2 seulement
quelques dizaines de kilomètres eh bien
les premières unités d'un virus
pénétrait peine et traite en ukraine
pour commencer cette invasion donc il ya
eu 25 jours d'occupation de cette
centrale une résistance héroïque du
personnel de la centrale nucléaire pour
tenter de contenir ces militaires russes
qui nous lisent et il était totalement
naïf ne savais même pas où il mettait
les pieds et se sont concentrées sur
fait de plier tous y était pia blue
venons de parcourir plusieurs une
centaine de kilomètres en direction
cette fois de deux kiev et je peux vous
dire que c'est une zone vermand de
désolation jeu sur les zones qui ont été
occupées pendant plus d'un mois avant
que la l'opération spéciale militaire
comme le décrit la dmr poutine et son
état major et bien change d'ambition
après l'échec de l'état de siège de la
ville de kiev de se concentrer sur
karkhiv c'était il ya un mois et
effectivement il y as nous avons
traversé des routes secondaires dans des
bois où il ya des centaines de bunkers
de l'armée russe tout est extrêmement
biner on vient et on venait en
provenaient en bout renvoyer des soldats
d'ukrainiens qui mettaient des badauds
indiquant qu'il y avait des mines
partout des vies des visages des
villages avec des des scènes de
dévastation et puis encore et toujours
cette histoire sur laquelle nous
travaillons depuis trois jours à
sillonner cette région et bien cet après
guerre avec état de choc des populations
avec des récits absolument effroyable de
viol par centaines de disparitions et 1
et 2 et d'exécutions sommaires ce qu'ils
ont créé en forme de bilan allant
prenante dans le quatrième mois de cette
opération spéciale militaire russe et
bien ce bilan c'est que ce conte ce à
quoi ont donné un assist ici c'est
évidemment ce qui se passe actuellement
dans des zones occupées par l'armée
russe donc on pense évidemment à tout
l'est de l'ukraine le drogba sous les
combats font rage mais elle a créé mais
aussi ou encore marioupol dont les
premiers témoignages arrivent et sont
aussi plaçant cyril payen en direct
d'hosto mails envoyés